when we get up in the morning we start
to do things first we might shower get
dressed and brush our teeth we might see
this as a trivial string of items we
just need to get through to prepare for
our day we might have a commute in the
morning we might see this as a hassle as
a means to our destination perhaps we
might drive fast and try to get to where
we are going as soon as possible even if
we're not late during the day when we
are at work or school or wherever we are
we might feel that what we are doing is
boring stressful or annoying
we might stare at a clock attempting to
contort each minute into seconds
hoping that what we are doing will be
over soon so it can just be lunchtime at
lunch we might go to one of our favorite
eateries there might be a line we might
agitatedly stand in this line wanting it
to be over as soon as possible so we can
finally get our food and eat once we get
our food we might rush through it so we
can play on our phone or watch something
on a computer before returning to work
or school after lunch we might pick back
up where we left off we might continue
looking at the clock just wanting the
day to be over at this point so we can
return home and relax once the day is
over and we are home we might have some
dinner
we might be annoyed that we have to deal
with preparing it we might try to think
of a meal that is quick and easy so we
don't have to spend too much time on it
or maybe we might order out so to avoid
dealing with it at all once we start our
dinner we might eat somewhat quickly so
we can move on with our night and finish
up anything we still have left for the
day or perhaps we can just watch some TV
and go to bed early so we aren't too
tired tomorrow
tomorrow will be the same tomorrow will
be another string of moments that we see
as means to the next
another day we see as a means to
tomorrow but here we would be living in
the previous moments next moment and
yesterday's tomorrow over and over
waiting for things to get better if we
are one of the fortunate ones we might
realize in one of our days that it is
not necessarily our days that will get
much better but ourself if we are lucky
the next day we might feel the water
roll over our skin and savor the
refreshing cleansing sensation when
taking a shower when getting dressed
we might be deliberate in what we choose
to wear and find it fun that we get to
form our own style like we are creating
an arts and crafts piece out of our own
body every day when we commute to work
we might look out the window and become
fully aware of our surroundings noticing
the little details of the world
wondering where it all came from and
where it all might go enthralled with
curiosity and or if we are in traffic or
in a long line somewhere we might
appreciate that we are somewhere that is
popular and worth being it when we are
eating we might think about each bite
and be grateful that we live on a planet
with all the nutrients we need to keep
our body alive during the day we might
focus on what we are doing and
appreciate that we can do anything and
know that we are doing it if we are wise
we might realize that perhaps it isn't
merely what our days contain that makes
our days better but how we choose to see
and experience what our days contain how
we choose to treat each moment how we
choose to plant the roses we want to
smell instead of hoping we will find
them
thank you for watching if he found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and Wonder